before we get into this video I wanted
to note that usually I would pull in
relevant chunks of gameplay when doing
one of these videos to show you the
thing I'm talking about I chose not to
do that this time around because I'm
aware there are a lot of people who are
conscious about spoilers I will only be
showing initial trailer gameplay just to
give you something else to look at other
than my stupid face but want to confirm
that this video is completely spoiler
free including gameplay for anyone who's
interested hello everyone I'm Alana
Orchard and welcome to my channel where
today I am answering the questions you
guys have left me about Starfield I've
been playing the game for about 25 hours
now feels like I'm barely scratching the
surface it is a very big game but to
very quickly answer a question that I
have seen actually related to that I
don't feel like it's overwhelmingly big
in all of my early reaction videos I was
like I'm just hoping that like if I'm
not interested in a certain thing I
don't have to do it and that is totally
the case you can kind of opt in in what
you want to to Starfield and leave
everything else behind and that is
A-Okay let's get to the official
questions so the most common question
that I got that I have already addressed
in a separate video is about space
exploration somebody here asked how long
does it take to fly from Earth to the
sun it is effectively impossible to do
that I did already address this part of
it in a video again because it's the
most common question stuff you guys
asked and I think I'm going to do a
stream maybe even tonight where I'm
going to leave my ship flying towards
Earth for as long as possible and see if
we even inch closer apparently a
streamer did manage to clip through a
planet I haven't been able to find that
I don't know what it looks like
um but effectively space travel is
extremely limited because things are
just too far away obviously that's
realistic but there are a lot of ways in
which space in Starfield isn't realistic
like for example there is plenty of
sound there's also this thing where if
you boost while flying your spaceship
and then you stop boosting you will slow
down even though that technically
shouldn't be physically possible but
that's why we make limitations in video
games realism isn't necessarily fun to
play which is why it's kind of a bummer
that you can't like actually fly around
a solar system you are essentially just
fast traveling and to be honest that is
a very big part of the game there are
other things that I really really really
like about Starfield but I did find it
to be a little bit of a bummer that it's
not really a space travel of space
exploration game it is actually not like
no man's sky where you can just take off
from a planet see another planet and fly
there it's not like that I think the
biggest downside of Starfield is the
amount of time that you spend in menu
you spend a lot of time in menus and you
spend a lot of time fast traveling uh I
think before it came out I was being
like yeah some parts of this are really
fast travel simulator so yeah space
um exploration not really that much of a
thing you will only ever really get in
your ship kind of if you want to you
don't even have to all the time as sort
of an in-between few seconds sometimes
before landing on a planet and landing
on a planet is something you do also
have to do from a menu most of the time
so the space exploration is quite
limited I don't know that you actually
can ever fly into a Sun or a gas giant I
really wanted to try it because I was
like oh what would happen but of course
they haven't developed atmospheres and
physics for each individual gas planet
to rip you apart like that would be a
lot but yes most common question I got
have already made a video about it there
isn't too much space exploration that
said space does look gorgeous when
you're out there Hollister ledge said my
question is do you receive any items or
other bonuses to your character when you
collect this kid stuff trait where you
have to send two percent of your credits
to your parents in order to visit them
uh it's not in order to visit them it's
just you just have to send them the two
percent I don't think that ever ends um
you got a backpack that has extra
inventory which is very important in
this game because another one of my
bigger criticisms would be the amount of
inventory management that's required you
get over encumbered so fast and at the
start it's definitely a bit confusing
because you have all these like separate
things you can delve into like there are
these research tasks that'll let you
craft things but like if you're not
carrying the stuff that you need for the
research task you think that you can't
do the research but you don't know what
you need to carry at the start of the
game so you're just like kind of taking
on everything and you get over encumbent
very quickly the fitness and
weightlifting skills are both helpful
with that but yes they give you a
backpack it's a school backpack but it
does give you extra space and they'll
send you notes and they'll like Ping you
um they'll come visit constellation I
imagine you continue to get stuff from
them it's been a while since I went and
said hi to Mom and Dad to be honest yeah
you don't just have to go to their house
to visit them you can visit them
um in other places or they'll come to
visit you one red one said how's the
planet exploration felt so far also have
the map boundaries affected your
enjoyment at all yeah so where I said
that I think space travel is limited and
I am a little disappointed by that I'm
actually not personally disappointed by
the map boundaries at all so a lot of
planets are Barren and boring that's
the truth about the world about the real
space right a lot of planets are Barren
and boring most of them have nothing on
them that is effect and that is the case
here as it is the case in Mass Effect
and there are various planets that have
big cities and all the big cities do
look super different to one another and
are very fun to spend time in they feel
like totally different worlds they're
almost like little theme park areas that
you can like travel to like one's a
western area and one's a cyberpunky area
they're all super super different and
and I love that about it but when it
comes to Planet exploration this is a
thing that I actually like the least
about the game but also I'm totally okay
with when considering the whole package
like it really bothered me initially and
and it's bothering me less now that I'm
playing more of it like I love
exploration in a Bethesda RPG like you
know getting out of the vault in Fallout
and being like I might go here and you
just wander off in a direction and you
find some super cool side quests or some
Outpost that's just doing like crazy
stuff or some settlement that's just
like nothing you could ever have
imagined I I love that so much in um
Elder Scrolls and in Fallout just
wondering and seeing what you'll find I
have not found any of that in Starfield
there is no wonder and see what you'll
find in terms of like actual Planetary
Exploration I've gone to several
outposts on multiple planets um because
you know you'll see like this used to be
a settlement and then you go there every
single time I have not yet found a
single exception I'm sure they exist as
I keep playing the game but I've not
found any which like makes it
off-putting to even do when you know you
see like there's a main city and then
there's a separate place you can land
another place you can land they are
always just like a couple of buildings
usually some dead scientists and some
space pirates who immediately want to
shoot me you can maybe find some weapons
and stuff there but I've not found any
of the like stumble across
an outpost that has an interesting story
thing that is so awesome in Fallout and
yeah at first that really bothered me
because that was part of my expectation
which I think is on me because uh that's
what I want for over there's RPG that is
not here so like even if you're at one
of those like the many planets I've
landed on just to like try and find that
kind of thing by going somewhere else
and then you walk away from it generally
when you walk away you're not going to
find anything else there might be like
another couple of random buildings but
then it just starts to be like
environments that are just kind of
repeated the part that doesn't bother me
at all is the map boundaries it takes
about 15 minutes walking in One
Direction and that's just in One
Direction like it's still a square so
that's just one way
before it'll be like hey you need to get
back to the ship walking straight for 15
minutes in a video game that has so much
other stuff to do it's just not
something you would ever do unless
you're trying to do what I did which is
test the limit it's a very long time and
there's not that much in that space that
you would need to find otherwise So in
theory I get people criticizing not
being able to like walk around an entire
planet but practically I think the
amount of people who would actually ever
do that I would never actually do that
is just so so so small unless it were a
multiplayer game like a Minecraft map
where you have multiple people on a
server but it's not there are also no
land Vehicles which um I think is also
kind of a bummer but makes sense
considering the limitations to the map
but like I just can't see any reason why
you would ever actually want to do that
so no I do not feel negatively about the
map boundaries but the Planetary
Exploration is certainly not really a
part of this game and so what I'm
talking about that being the thing that
I initially really liked the least will
probably still do like the least um even
though I would have also loved some of
the space exploration as well I love
events guy the the thing that they
replace that with is a thing that I am
obsessed with there is a thing in
Starfield that is so unbelievably good
there are just so many side quests in
this game that are so in-depth like they
go forever and you get so immersed in
this
world and these people and what they're
having you do there are some side quests
that are very throwaway and very simple
um something will only take five minutes
but uh in my second playthrough um the
one that I'm streaming I'm just like
applying for a bunch of jobs and there
are multiple people across various
planets that have job listings available
there's one where someone's assistant I
did that a little on my first
playthrough um there's one where I
technically applied for like a junior
operatives job I think I started as
admin and then became an operative I'm
like doing corporate Espionage for this
company there's so much dialogue such
great voice acting across the board and
so many parts that you can just like go
further and further and further down
without even looking at the rest of the
game I'd say it's like not quite as
creative in terms of what you can
actually do as something like Baldur's
Gate 3 and it's kind of a shame these
games have come out next to each other
for both of these games like I want both
of them to steal my life but I only have
one life but it's a huge step above
previous Bethesda RPGs and frankly vast
majority of RPGs it's so much fun and
you can just keep going and that's why I
highly recommend that you get involved
in factions when you can I did this on
my main playthrough there is so much
drama that you will just get drawn into
and people to talk to and stuff to do
that like will have you not shooting a
single person for hours which I just I'm
obsessed with it it's fantastic it's so
much fun and it still has like a bunch
of Bethesda like goofiness and silly
characters and yeah it's for for the
things that I'm like uh bummer that this
isn't here the stuff that is there you
clearly see the trade-off like they make
it very clear okay that was cut because
you can only fit so much [__] in one
video game in all of that is where they
put a lot of resources and the stuff
they put their resources into is so much
fun the shipboarding mechanic was the
coolest thing to me in the Showcase is
what are your impressions so far
um yeah the shipboarding stuff
is also very fun because you come across
people who like when you're flying
around who might be like hey can I chat
to you I've had like maybe four
encounters one with somebody called
Grandma so you can choose to board those
ships if you want to and like meet
people who may not be hostile of course
sometimes people might be tricking you
my favorite one of those so far has been
Grandma but that is also something that
I would definitely recommend doing
literally wherever you can if somebody
talks to you and you have the
opportunity to dock that ship you should
do it you spend so little time actually
in space and at first I found the ship
upgrades menu like super intimidating
frankly across the board the UI in this
game is not very good things are
overwhelming um there's just so much
information at all times and it's not
like super user friendly and it'll take
you a long time to get into anything but
yes the shipboarding stuff is really
really really fun they've made it super
creative with the kinds of people that
you will meet David Scandal said I would
love to know about the performance so
far not necessarily detailed statistics
or anything but just your experience
with the smoothness of movement and
consistency uh such as have you
experienced any drops and frames in
cluttered environments or larger combat
scenarios great question uh this is the
most polished Bethesda game I have ever
played it is the most bug-free Bethesda
game I have ever played by a mild they
clearly had extra time to polish and
clearly use the time well in my opinion
it's night and day almost to the extent
that I sort of Miss it a little that
like I feel like some of the Bethesda
Jank has like become a quirk of their
games that I was like oh
it functions the only two bugs that I
have encountered at all I'm pretty sure
at least uh one where there was a pretty
big explosion and somebody's head got
stuck in a ceiling but I was like well
technically that could happen like does
that count as a bug like there could be
an explosion that would like smash
somebody's head through a ceiling and
his body was just dangling and like that
doesn't seem impossible the other one
was a very early quest mission where I
just on my second playthrough did not
have the option to engage in dialogue
where I did the first time I'm not
actually positive if that went down that
way it might have been that like maybe
on my second playthrough because of an
allegiance I had I wasn't able to engage
with him and I just had to shoot him but
he was standing there waiting to talk to
me it was a quest icon and I couldn't
talk to him so that's a pretty big bug
uh but that's in you know the 20 plus
hours that I played the only two that I
have found in terms of frame rate drops
they happen sort of often but only last
like a second it's as though I'm getting
occasional loads they are never
consistent I haven't had one last more
than probably literally a a second or
two some in big cities actually more so
when I'm exploring planets which again
not a thing that I think is very
interesting here but yes less buggy than
most Bethesda games it still has some of
the Bethesda Jank if we want to call it
that where like like I just think it's
so weird that when you walk through
anyway everyone just kind of stares at
you like just blankly like there are
also things where like if you start a
conversation with someone and they're
not immediately looking at you they're
just like sort of staring ahead and then
they have to eventually hear
because it doesn't have the ability to
like flip their whole body most of the
time so there's just like a bunch of
silly funny stuff that uh is still
certainly there but yeah their most
polished game upon release to date which
um is definitely impressive considering
the amount of [__] you can do in this
game like it is there are so many things
you can delve into what are the romance
options like can you actually get down
with someone so I wasn't sure about this
initially so to ask other people because
I had a character that I flirted with a
couple of times but I was ultimately
rejected she told me she wasn't
interested
um so I wasn't able to pursue that but
yes you can romance characters and have
relationships with them I think with
most of your companions I'm not actually
totally sure but as long as you spend
enough time with somebody you will
eventually get an option to flirt with
them and I guess you can see where it
goes from there obviously can be
rejected it happened to me apparently I
have no risks blah blah Wesson said to
the world's build empty or the summer
really flushed out and some that are
blank seems difficult to populate space
make it rewarding to explore so I think
I already touched on this a little bit
but let me delve into it a little
further all of the worlds feel empty in
my opinion they all feel empty there are
just cities that act as hubs that aren't
empty
but everything outside of those cities
empty at least that's the case for
everything that I've seen so 100 of the
worlds feel empty some more than others
some at least have aliens some don't
seem to have aliens there will be like I
said those outposts where you fight
Pirates but that's really all I found to
do again this is just what I've found
it's a very big game everything is very
separate it's not just one big map that
you could walk across so there's like so
much that I I'm sure I just haven't even
seen I want to be super clear about that
but from what I have seen every World
feels empty and I'm not interested in
going to vast majority of them or even
looking at vast majority of them the
cities do not feel empty the cities feel
great and again very distinct from each
other but in terms of actual planets
most of them have nothing to do which is
the case for the real world also p50
account said how useful is the speech
skill also said how soon can you start
Mission with your ship realistically and
building an outpost that's an easy one
very soon you can start that stuff like
almost straight away maybe an hour in
um the speech skill is one that I kind
of recommend everybody makes the game
more fun I don't love the persuasion
mechanic in this game
um it is more like Oblivion apparently
which like I've played Oblivion but it
was in 2006 like I was a child like I I
played the [__] out of that game when it
came out I don't even remember the
speech mechanic do you just get a bunch
of pluses and some of them are red and
some of them are green the green ones
are easier the red ones are seemingly
impossible and then sometimes says like
a bluish green one that is there because
you've gotten information about the
person you're talking to and so it's an
easier skill check then you have a
certain amount of times you get to try
to persuade them like say it's five down
the bottom you have to choose the
dialogue options and you only have five
times to do it to actually persuade them
I don't like the system very much like
you really just should go with the green
every time I can't see why you wouldn't
otherwise you're just gonna fail but
letting information about somebody and
then having that healthy persuade is
super fun so I don't like the persuasion
mechanic I like fallout's persuasion
mechanic a lot better that said I will
say the lock picking in this game I
think is the best lock picking that has
ever been in any game this is the best
lock picking in any video game ever they
finally figured it out you get these
things called Digi picks which you got
to pick up all of them highly recommend
and there are several circles and you
have to figure out how to put like a key
in each circle but they can overlap I'm
explaining this terribly but um the lock
picking mechanic absolutely rules it
persuasion not so much just a preference
though I prefer Fallout or like bg3 like
having a percentage kind of thing how do
you feel about character customization
in terms of the different backgrounds
yeah it's a tough one because like this
happens at the start of most these games
where you have no idea what you're doing
so you're like I don't know
this and I've not felt like my
backgrounds for either my two characters
which are quite different have
had a huge play on anything yet they're
there and it's cool that they're there
but I don't feel super strongly about
them at this stage they're they're okay
it's fun to like pick that stuff and
like have that help with you as you role
play which again this is a role-playing
game what you're gonna be doing most of
the time is role playing the game is
built for you to literally role play
like nerdiest nerd role play get
involved in the world and be like this
is who I am this is what I'm doing and
just get into that and if you do like in
a DND way I think it's super rewarding
so they're more of like a framework to
help your imagination than anything else
I would have thought but maybe there's
more to it later on I don't know at this
stage they're okay as far as RPGs go how
would you classify the puck system is
there a game you can compare it to as
far as depth or longevity in a
playthrough I mean it's pretty similar
to Fallout 76 to be honest are there
other things you can level up or just
solely the perk system for character
progression yeah so there are a bunch of
perks Parks have multiple tiers for each
I think and they also have challenges so
you won't actually be able to get to the
next
um level of a certain perk unless you've
completed the challenges associated with
that perk which I really like so like
the persuasion perk you have to pass
three checks before you can unlock level
two on that and there are four separate
or five separate brackets of things like
there's a science
social like body or Fitness one and and
as you unlock the first row of any of
those you will then be able to unlock a
second row and get deeper and deeper
into it this is another sort of menu
inside a menu inside of menu which is an
issue with the game but I actually
really like the level up system I do
really like that you need to specialize
in your perks and it won't just let you
keep leveling up when you aren't using
them and it's fun to like see what your
starting options are in a certain
bracket of the thing you might want to
focus on and like know how much is below
it and how many levels there are below
it that you can't even access yet and
actually seeing it in front of you is
really nice but it is quite simple in a
way that I also like so I'm a fan of the
level up system it's good flyback said
my question is from the footage I've
seen so far I'm afraid stuff it'll be
filled with different mechanic systems
and things to explore but lacks all and
feel a bit generic to play can you give
me your impressions on this please yes
and no it is filled with a lot of
different mechanics not that many things
to explore and it definitely has Soul it
does not feel generic to play but that
requires you to play it a certain way
which is the fully go down a path and
get lost in it way which makes the game
like so rewarding so much more than vast
majority of video games it rules but you
have to do that like if you want to get
really involved in dog fighting or ships
you would really just have to commit to
that life and and start recruiting
people to your ship and leveling up your
ship and like start taking over other
ships sell parts buy parts I get very
into that thing and if you only like
touch on things from the surface yes I
would say it probably feels generic to
play which again I think is the thing I
was saying with the early game players
like I feel like I'm gonna have to pick
and choose what to get involved in here
and not get involved in everything
because there is just too much and that
is definitely true you have to like pick
a thing that you're like let's do this
and just go for it do dialogue options
actually feel like options examples some
games have text options are a veil of
choice where NPC responses don't
actually change mace much on wow I've
messed that sense up change much based
on what you say
this is a great question yes
you can absolutely like have things
happen that you lock off an entire Quest
lock off an entire person like fail at
something badly because you went down
the wrong path or dialogue options the
illusion of choice
um is not so much an illusion where
that's concerned but also some parts of
this can be like a little bit broken
like you can say something because you
have this like big tree of things to say
and then you get back to the first
dialogue menu and say another thing
there and they've like forgotten the
previous conversation like they're not
great with context or like the NPCs
aren't great at remembering the
conversation you've already had unless
it's one of the ones that like locks you
out completely or progresses something
significantly so it's not like
completely shallow you you what you say
does matter
like you could say something early in a
conversation that will like completely
[__] up the end of the conversation and
you'll end up having to have combat
where you didn't want it or whatever but
it's not as deep as you like might like
it to be in terms of yeah they'll forget
stuff you've said to them before pretty
often the NPCs are not great with
context Keo said how do you feel about
the combat is it as bad as it looks the
combat is one of the weaker parts of the
game I'm not very uh into it um they've
added some fun new stuff for sure which
I won't even spoil because you can see
it for yourself but I will do anything I
can to talk my way out of combat and
that certainly is a fair bit of combat
in a lot of the
um quests you're fighting very generic
enemies the AI is okay the Gunplay is
bethesda's Best Yet by a mile but it's
not like fantastic compared to the rest
of the industry it's a thing that's
there that has you'll find some fun guns
that are fun to use and some abilities
and stuff but overall it's okay Leah
bustle said how many hours of gameplay
can we expect expect replayability I
imagine you can expect hundreds of hours
out of this game it's so big and there's
so much to do I don't know about
replayability
um because I imagine most people will
just want to go one save file I guess
that's not true I have two save files
I'm playing very differently on both of
them and I'm enjoying the way I'm
playing on both of them it's different
for both so in terms of those
you're good you got lots to do what's
your opinion on the main questline so
far if you've played any of it yeah so I
mostly played the main quest line uh on
my main character that is what I focused
on and it's a simple and premise but
pretty solid in terms of like the way it
does the story out to you but it is
definitely like you need to find these
things go find them and it does have
some pretty big wondrous moments for
sure so I like the main story the music
is also very good across the board I
think if they do a really good job with
that ambient music the professor RPGs
have always been really good at ramps up
at the right times calms down at the
right times yeah the music is is
beautiful honestly tme 8 said did you
have a moment where you've fully
enveloped into the world of Starfield
sort of like the moment in Skyrim where
you enter the world for the first time
after leaving the cave no and that is
one of the biggest struggles with this
game is you do not have the leave the
cave leave the Vault Moment Like I said
earlier maybe the first time you fly
into space can feel a little bit like
that but ultimately this is a very
different game where you're not just
exploring one world and so it doesn't
feel that way and I think that that is
going to put a lot of people off
ultimately but you don't have this like
big like here you go so it's very
fractured here you goes he's it makes
the pacing very different compared to
their other games
um yeah it does not have that moment in
my opinion hybrid 420 said how is the
base buildings the scene putting seem
like putting time into the base building
is basically Fallout 4 space building
but a little bit more expansive and yes
it does seem like a lot of fun I've not
gotten too far into it but I like it
it's very complicated when you first
look at it like it's a lot the menu is
very hectic but I think uh when I choose
to delve more into that I'm gonna have a
great time I think that's most of the
questions answered here like I'm as I'm
scrolling now I'm getting to the same
ones and I definitely don't want to
spoil anything so I'm uh hesitant with
that yeah they're all the same now but
we did get a lot of questions here so if
there's anything big that I haven't
answered in this video let me know and I
can make another one potentially next
week games on that yet of course it's
not an early access and more people are
playing it but they're happy to keep
talking about it I'm also streaming a
lot of the game uh for anyone who is
interested in that there are a bunch of
people who've asked me like do I see the
game being as expensive with mods as
Fallout and Elder Scrolls and I would
say yes I think the mods are going to be
a ton of fun that is it from me right
now let me know if you have more
questions I don't mind making a part two
this game's so goddamn big uh we'll be
streaming it virtually every day that I
can
um
I'm having a lot of fun streaming it and
yeah thank you so much for asking
questions I appreciate y'all bye